JOSKOW: Good evening.
Welcome to today's Council on Foreign Relations
meeting: "Power, Partnership, and Presence:
U.S. Navy Leadership."
We're pleased to welcome Secretary of the
Navy Ray Mabus to the-to the Council.
This evening's session will focus on the secretary's
programs to reduce the Navy's reliance on
fossil fuels, grow its utilization of alternative
energy, and to pursue energy security in the-in
the face of global climate change.
Secretary Mabus will first make a few brief
remarks, then I'll ask him some questions,
and then we'll give the members of the Council
a chance to ask questions as well.
Mr. Secretary.
MABUS: Great.
Doctor, thank you so much, and thank you all
for being here.
The two questions I get asked the most are,
why does the Navy need as big fleet as we
have, and why in the world is the Navy worried
about energy?
The answer to both those questions is the
thing that the Navy and Marine Corps uniquely
give to this country is presence.
There is no next best thing to being there-being
in the right place not just at the right time,
but all the time.
So we are growing the Navy fleet after years
of decline.
In 2001, there were 316 ships in the U.S.
Navy.
By 2008, after one of the great military buildups
in our history, we were down to 278 ships.
In that period, those seven years, the Navy
put 41 ships under contract-not enough to
keep our fleet from declining and not enough
to keep our shipyards in business.
As of last week, I've been in this job for
seven years, so it's an exact comparison.
I've put 85 ships under contract in the same
period with a smaller top line.
And so we're going to grow the fleet.
We'll have 300 ships again by 2019, and 306-308,
which is our demonstrated need-it's our assessed
need-by 2021.
And the second question: Why is the secretary
of the Navy, and why is the U.S. Navy, worried
about energy, about power?
And one thing is historic.
We've always been on the cutting edge of energy
change.
We went from sail to coal in the middle of
the 19th century.
We went from coal to oil in the early 20th
century.
We pioneered the use of nuclear for propulsion
in the middle of the 20th century.
And every single time we did that, there were
naysayers.
You're trading something that's free, the
wind, for something that costs money, coal.
Or, you're abandoning all those coaling stations
around the world for oil.
Or, there is no way that you can make nuclear
small enough and safe enough to put in a submarine.
Every single time, the naysayers were wrong.
They're wrong this time.
We're doing it for several reasons.
One is-and the reason we started down this
path-is to be better warfighters.
Energy can be used as a weapon, and it is
used as a weapon.
Look at what Russia did to Crimea.
Look at what Russia did to Ukraine.
Look at what Russia tried to do to Europe
before the price of oil bottomed out.
I did not want that used as a weapon against
us.
Secondly, the cost of both price shocks and
supply shocks in energy.
Because oil is a global commodity, we don't
control the price.
It goes up and down.
But in the first couple of years that I was
there I was presented with more than $2 billion
in unbudgeted price hikes because of energy.
And even in the Pentagon, finding $2 billion
that's unplanned for is not an-not an easy
task.
The other thing is, we were losing a Marine
killed or wounded for every 50 convoys of
fuel we brought into Afghanistan, and that's
too high a price to pay.
So, in 2009, I came up with some energy goals
that by-the biggest of which, by 2020, at
least half of all naval energy afloat and
ashore would come from non-fossil fuel sources.
We're there on our bases today.
We got there by the end of 2015.
Half of the power that is under contract for
our bases-so, more than a gigawatt we have
under contract for our bases.
So we're five years early doing that.
In the fleet, 30 percent now is alternative,
and it's growing.
We've got the Great Green Fleet at sea right
now, which is-the carrier is nuclear, the
surface ships where they're sailing on a blend
of marine diesel and biofuels.
The Marines are making energy where they are
with things like very small solar panels that
are rollable-put it in your pack, power your
GPS, power your radios with that.
It saves a company of Marines 700 pounds of
batteries that they don't have to carry.
They are also using things like portable solar
for their-for their tents, for where they
live, for all their power.
Once you turn the generators off, number one,
you can hear if the bad guys are sneaking
up on you; and, number two, you take a target
off yourself because everybody knows where
you are if you've got a generator going.
But the second reason is climate change.
As we move forward, the Navy and the Marine
Corps are our first responders.
So, as the Arctic opens up and is ice-free
now, and you've got shipping lanes, the Navy
is going to be the one to maintain freedom
of navigation through that as you get contests
for minerals in the Arctic, in the South China
Sea, off the coast of Africa in the Gulf of
Gabon.
It's the U.S. Navy that is the first responder.
As sea levels rise and chaos and instability
follows, it's the Navy and Marine Corps.
And the estimates are that in the not-too-distant
future, 100 to 200 million people are going
to be displaced by this because 70 percent
of the world's population lives within 60
miles of the ocean.
And then we have bases on the ocean.
It makes sense that we do.
And they're going to be threatened with rising
sea levels.
And so it's for a couple of reasons.
One is warfighting.
Two is just the effects of climate change
and our need to do something about it, because
it has a direct impact on our responsibilities.
And the final thing I'll say is, once you
do the ships and power to drive those ships
and to get those ships where they need to
be, and those aircraft, we have to have the
sailors and Marines to actually fly them and
sail them.
And so the other thing that I'm extremely
proud of-and we'll, I hope, get into this
more-are some of the personnel initiatives
that we've taken.
We were talking about it backstage.
We brought Navy ROTC back to Harvard, Yale,
Princeton, Columbia, after an absence of 40
years.
But we also brought it to Rutgers and Arizona
State, the two most diverse campuses in this
country.
I opened up submarines and riverines to women,
and just opened up all ground combat positions
to women, because if you set standards, if
you make those job-related, and you don't
relax them, then to tell somebody you cannot
do it because of the shape of your skin or
because of who you love or because of the
color of your skin is just wrong.
And we are a stronger force because we're
a more diverse force, because people with
different backgrounds think differently, they
bring different problem-solving skillsets.
I tripled paid maternity leave for sailors
and Marines from six weeks to 18 weeks.
We're opening childcare two hours earlier,
leaving them open two hours later.
And again, it's to make us a better force.
And I think that we are much stronger today
than we were a few years ago, when we were
excluding people because of their gender,
because of their sexual orientation, and because
of the color of their skin.
So, again, thank you all for being here, and
I look forward to it.
JOSKOW: Thank you.
Thank you, Mr. Secretary.
Let's stay on the personnel side of the equation.
Have the senior military staff embraced your
alternative fuels and energy efficiency programs,
or have you encountered resistance from them?
MABUS: Well, when we first started-when I
first started, in 2009, we were hard-pressed
to find two flag officers that you could get
to endorse this.
We just did a conference on alternative energy
at National Defense University, and my energy
office did a film of flag officers endorsing
this and talking about why it was important.
And we had two single-spaced, typed pages
of flag officers wanting to be on the record
for this because they understand-because they've
seen it in action-it makes us better.
It makes us better warfighters.
So you've got the chief of naval operations,
you've got the commandant of the Marine Corps
pushing for this.
And, as important as that is, you've also
got that third class petty officer and that
lance corporal, because that lance corporal
doesn't have to carry the batteries, suddenly,
and that lance corporal doesn't have to guard
a fuel convoy coming into Afghanistan or Iraq;
and that third class petty officer is figuring
out how to save energy on the equipment that
he runs on the ship.
And so it's a culture change, and it's permeated
the fleet.
And it's because we really are better at our
jobs because of this.
And they're the ones that have to do these
jobs, and they're the ones that are on the
tip of the spear doing it.
They're the ones that see the impact the quickest.
JOSKOW: You count nuclear power as an alternative
energy source-
MABUS: I do.
JOSKOW: -and that's not true in all of the
U.S. states that have programs in this regard.
How important do you see nuclear energy being
in the-in the future, as you make this transition?
MABUS: Well, we are 17 percent nuclear at
sea.
All our submarines, all our carriers are nuclear.
We tried it on other surface ships in the
'80s-cruisers, in particular.
It's probably not going back there because
it's just not economically feasible right
now.
Oil has to be over about $240 a barrel for
an extended period of time to make it economic.
The reason it is feasible for submarines and
carriers is that it's more expensive, but
it gives us a combat edge.
The carriers have to be refueled ever 25 years.
The submarines that we're building today never
have to be refueled, so you never have to
take them off the line to do that.
Even though it's more expensive, it gives
us an edge.
And I don't ever want to send sailors or Marines
into a fair fight.
I want them to have an edge.
And I think nuclear power, particularly at
sea, does that.
And, you know, I'll go one step further.
We're not looking at it onshore, but I do
think we should, at particularly distributed
smaller things that-with some of the new technology
that's coming along, it's much safer, it produces
far less residue and nuclear waste.
And, you know, it is an option that I think
we should-we should explore.
JOSKOW: And a second alternative source are
biofuel blends that you're-have there been
any challenges in using the biofuel blends
in ships and other applications?
MABUS: No challenge about the fuels.
I mean, we've got three requirements for biofuels.
Number one, it's got to be a drop-in fuel.
We're not changing our engines.
We're not changing how they run.
So, for ships and aircraft-and we've certified
every single ship and aircraft on biofuels.
Number two, it can't take any land out of
food production.
We don't want to be competing for that.
And, number three, it's got to be cost competitive.
So we didn't have any challenges putting it
in the fleet.
I mean, the engines didn't notice the difference.
The only difference we can tell is they burn
a little cleaner.
Engines last a little bit longer with biofuels
than they do.
But the challenge that we had, the first batch
we bought, in 2012, was a test batch-you know,
it was very small.
We sent it out to proof of concept to make
sure we could refuel at sea, that we could
refuel air-to-air, to make sure that we could
put it in our misnamed "oilers" and take it
to sea.
We paid $25 a gallon for that because it was
a small batch and there was just no scale
to it.
And so we got hammered for doing that, even
though first of a class, early adapters.
I mean, smartphones are way more expensive
than rotary dial.
Computers are more expensive than typewriters.
So technology sometimes is more expensive.
But, now that we've gotten to scale, the fuel
that we bought, that's now being used at sea
in the Stennis Carrier Strike Group and also
the carrier strike group that's in the Mediterranean
right now, we paid less than $2 a gallon for
that.
So even-and it was just a normal solicitation.
It wasn't, "Biofuel companies, give us your
bid."
It was, "Here's the fuel we need," and biofuels
companies bid, a mixture.
And they were successful in doing it.
So even with oil at these very low prices,
it's competitive now.
And so it's become the new normal.
JOSKOW: Have our allies' navies learned lessons
from what you're doing?
MABUS: They have.
We've got agreements with Australia, with
Chile, with Japan.
We're going to refuel, and we have been refueling-I'm
going in two weeks to Italy to-we're doing
an exercise at sea with the Italians.
We're going to refuel them with biofuels.
And they've got a biofuel plant now in Venice.
And Rim of the Pacific, the biggest naval
exercise in the world, every two years, we're
refueling the Japanese, we're refueling the
Chileans, we're refueling the Singaporeans,
we're refueling the Koreans, we're refueling
the Australians with biofuels, or with a mixture
of biofuels.
And the first time we did it, on the USS Nimitz
at RIMPAC in 2012, the vice chief of the Australian
Navy came over by helicopter and we did a
big press event, and somebody said-asked him,
said, how committed are you to biofuels?
And he said, well, they're refueling that
helicopter I just came over on, I'm about
to get back on it.
So I'm pretty committed to this-(laughter,
laughs)-to this whole thing.
And the last example I'll give you is, in
Singapore, there are two refineries.
One's an oil refinery, mostly owned by the
Chinese.
Right down the road is a biofuel refinery
owned by a Finnish company.
I don't want to be completely dependent on
the Chinese to refuel our ships in that part
of the world.
I want choice.
I want to be able to go somewhere else to
do it.
JOSKOW: It makes a lot of sense.
Have you found any partnerships with the private
sector to be useful, or not?
MABUS: Well, we've invested in three biofuel
plants.
They come from-they've got completely different
feedstocks.
And they're going to come online by 2017,
and they'll produce about 100 million gallons
a year, and they have to compete in terms
of price.
But airlines now are-most of them are flying
on at least some biofuels.
I mean, United has an investment in a biofuel
refinery, FedEx, UPS, Virgin, Alaska, all
are flying on at least a mixture of biofuels.
And part of that is just-I mean, they're all
in the business of making money.
Europe has got carbon restrictions now, so
if you're going to fly into Europe, you better
lower your carbon footprint or it's going
to cost you-cost you some money.
But they also sort of see the way the world
is going.
And I mean, as I said, these fuels, same chemical
composition, and their engines don't notice
a difference.
And if you can create a more stably priced,
homegrown source of energy, and it-you know,
it also gives another source of income to
people like farmers, which also is important.
JOSKOW: I know your-the size of the fleet's
going to increase first to 300, and then to
306 surface ships.
Is that creating challenges, or is that an
opportunity to design new ships that really
accommodate alternative fuels?
MABUS: Well, as I said, we're not changing
our engines at all.
Now, what we are doing is becoming way more
fuel efficient.
We're using a lot less oil.
We're using-the Navy's using 16 percent less
than we were seven years ago.
The Marine Corp's using 60 percent less than
it was seven years ago.
And so the-we've got two big-deck amphibious
ships, the USS Makin Island and the USS America,
that are hybrids, the Prius of the seas.
(Laughter.)
They have an electric drive for speeds under
12 knots and regular gas turbines for speeds
over 12 knots.
The first time the Makin Island went out on
patrol, they brought back 40 percent of their
fuel budget, and they stayed out 44 days longer.
But we're doing other stuff that's not nearly
as dramatic, but has a big impact.
If you change the lightbulbs on a destroyer
to LEDs, you save 20,000 gallons of fuel per
year on that destroyer, and you don't have
to change the lightbulbs but every seven years
instead of every six months, and it's better
light.
You can-you can actually see better.
We're doing stern flaps and hull coatings.
We're doing voyage planning like you did with
sailing ships, go with the-with the currents
instead of against them.
And so we're cutting way back.
We're doing the same thing, but just using
much less fuel.
And our ships, while they're becoming more
energy dependent-I mean, they're energy hogs
now.
The Zumwalt, the new destroyer that just launched,
is an all-electric ship.
Our new weapons systems-the railgun, the laser
weapon-are very energy-intensive.
But we're being able to have more energy density
on these ships using less-using less fuel
to do it.
JOSKOW: And if we turn to your fixed installations
in the U.S. and abroad, is it the same strategy-renewable
energy, alternative energy, energy efficiency?
MABUS: We're doing all of those things.
And, as I said, we are over a gigawatt.
We're 1.1 gigawatts now.
We use about 2 gigawatts a year on our shore
facilities.
We've got two seagoing services, the Navy
and the Marines.
But we also own 3 1/2 million acres of land
and 117,000 buildings.
So we're pretty big onshore too.
We're doing it all through public-private
partnerships.
We're doing it all so that private energy
companies can finance this over-that it's
financeable, that we do offtake contracts.
Sometimes it's on our land, sometimes it's
not.
But we're doing it on virtually every base.
And it's not just in California, it's also
in my home state of Mississippi, it's in Florida,
it's in Georgia, it's in the Northeast.
It's all over this country.
And public utilities have been some of our
best partners in moving toward alternative
energy.
And what we're doing now is we're moving to
microgrids, so that if something happens to
the grid we can keep doing our military business.
We can pull ourselves off the grid and continue
to do the defend and protect mission that
we're supposed to do.
JOSKOW: Well, it sounds like you're real leaders
in this area.
I hope others can learn from it.
Let me ask one final question before I open
it up to the members.
You spoke earlier about rising seas and-as
a result of climate change, and you have bases,
obviously, on the ocean.
Are you think about how you're going to accommodate
the changes in sea level in terms of where
your bases are, how they're structured, and
so on?
MABUS: We're having to.
Norfolk is probably the most at risk, and
it's not very far from having some real problems.
We've already got the first climate refugees
in the United States now.
An island in Louisiana disappeared, and it
was a story in The New York Times.
They had to be resettled in this country.
And so it's not a theoretical thing.
It's not something that may happen.
And you look in the Pacific, we're-you know,
the odds are we're going to have an existential
event there that we're going to lose a nation.
It's going to go under and it's going to disappear.
And a nation like Kiribati, which is about
a meter above sea level, you know, average,
and one of the things that the president there
said is that one of his main jobs is to convince
people to leave, to move somewhere.
This ought to concern us.
This ought to-this ought to be a worrisome
thing.
We ought to take a lot more action than what
we're doing.
I mean, I think the president's done-has taken
some pretty bold steps here.
And one of the things the military brings
is we're big enough; we can bring a market.
And we also have generally been leaders in
technology.
I mean, the internet, GPS, flat-screen TVs,
most-a lot of our medical advances started
in the military for military reasons, but
then migrated out to the civilian world.
And I think that that's happening here, too.
JOSKOW: Let me follow up on that, and then
I'll open it up for questions.
Do you have a dissemination program?
Are you trying to disseminate what you've
learned from this experience with the private
sector-with utilities, with business, with
the residences?
MABUS: Yeah, we're completely, completely
transparent.
We'll share with anybody.
And one of the things that happens is, if
you put it on base, it begins to migrate out.
If you-if you show it works-like, we just-we
just had the largest solicitation for electric
cars in history.
We've got over 50,000 non-combat vehicles,
and we drive them mostly on our bases, so
electric cars are pretty perfect for that.
But once you get charging stations on bases
and once you get charging stations near them,
it begins to spread.
And so that's-we're doing it overtly, but
we're also doing it just organically as well.
JOSKOW: That's great.
I'm sure you don't want a headline that says
"Navy Brass Buys $125,000 Teslas."
(Laughter.)
MABUS: (Laughs.)
Yeah, you're not going to see that.
(Laughs, laughter.)
JOSKOW: OK, very good.
Well, let me invite members to join the conversation
and to raise questions.
Let me remind everyone this is on the record.
And we have a microphone that will come around,
so you raise your hand and I'll call on you.
Wait for the microphone, tell us your name,
your affiliation.
And as I'm sure you all know, questions have
question marks at the end of them.
MABUS: (Laughs.)
JOSKOW: So questions and not speeches, thank
you.
Yes, in the-in the third row.
Q: Thank you.
Very, very interesting remarks, Mr. Secretary.
You brushed upon it, but almost reluctantly.
I mean, the Navy was the pioneer in nuclear
power.
My God, it almost invented it.
MABUS: Not reluctantly.
If I-if I gave that indication, it was a mistake.
Q: Well, I mean, it's the one source of non-fossil
fuel energy that can really move the needle.
MS.
: Can we have your name?
JOSKOW: I think-yes.
Q: I beg your pardon.
Richard Huber, InVina Wine.
We produce a nuclear fuel called wine in Chile.
MABUS: And we need a question.
Q: I said: Would you-would you-why are we
unwilling to develop that source?
You said 17 percent.
It should be 50 percent of the-I mean, the
Navy could be the leader in developing this
source of energy.
Why aren't we?
MABUS: Well, I would argue that we are, in
terms of we-most of the-of the nuclear technology
that comes out and is coming out now, most
of the research comes from ours-comes from
our research.
Now, there are differences because ours are
35-year reactors that aren't refueled.
Civilian reactors are refueled, on average,
about every two years.
And so you've got-you've got differences.
Also, a submarine doesn't take as much power
as a-as a community.
But some of the technology is-a lot of the
technology is very transferrable.
And as I said, one of the things that we are
looking at, but we haven't gotten there yet,
is distributed nuclear on bases and things
like that.
Not the huge plants, because in every source
of energy, regardless of what it is-whether
it's solar or conventional energy-it's becoming
much more distributed, much more making energy
exactly where you use it, and storing it where
you use it.
And so, you know, we are-we're definitely
not avoiding it.
Right now we can get, in terms of alternative
energy for our bases, you know, we are-as
I said, we're past 50 percent and we're continuing
to go doing stuff like wind and solar and
geothermal and hydrothermal, which economically
right now is cheaper.
And it's-and it's, very frankly, easier, as
you know.
JOSKOW: Yes, you were second.
Go ahead.
Q: I'm Phil Huyck with Encite Corporation.
There is school that suggests that, long term-and
we know where we all are in the long term-(laughter)-Keynes
put that very succinctly.
JOSKOW: And he was right.
Q: There is a school that suggests that fuel
cells, a hydrogen-based economy, is something
that eventually we will come to in a time
for another range of fuel cells.
As we know, solid oxide, proton-exchange membrane,
there's a range of technologies.
What is your focus on, and what's the Navy's
perspective on, fuel cells as an energy source?
MABUS: We've got several lines of effort on
fuel cells.
One is for unmanned underwater vehicles, so
that there is a technology-it's still in the
lab, but it's going to move out of the lab
I think pretty soon-that you mix organic matter
with seawater and you make hydrogen.
And so you can send down an unmanned underwater
vehicle; when it needs more power, it just
sinks down to the bottom, scoops up organic
material and mixes it with seawater-of which
there is a good bit in the ocean-(laughter)-and
it can stay out basically indefinitely.
So we're looking at that.
We have-we have been looking at fuel cells
also as power for our bases and our ships.
A little farther away, frankly, than some
of the other technology, but certainly a promising
area in the future.
And I have to say, I'm pretty neutral about
what sort of alternative energy you do-whether
it's nuclear, whether it's fuel cell, whether-whatever
feedstock it is for biofuels, whatever-you
know, if it comes from a landfill, if it comes
from camelina, if it comes from used cooking
oil, all of which we've bought, I don't really
care.
I do care about the carbon footprint, and
I care about the-about the fact that it doesn't
take any land out of food production, and
I care about the fact that we can get it easily.
I think fuel cells have a-have a very, very
bright future.
I'm not sure we're quite there in terms of
the technology that we need for-particularly
to drive things like a naval ship, yet.
JOSKOW: Let me try this side.
Yes.
Yep, second row.
Q: Hello, Mr. Secretary.
I'm George Stamas, old friend.
We've spent 40 minutes talking about innovation,
extraordinary innovation by the Navy.
I might add this new weapon that you've created
is also a source of great innovation, that
we've all been reading about this weekend.
Can you speak to the relationship with the
private sector, this spirit of innovation?
And I know you spend a lot of time in Silicon
Valley.
How do you keep up that private-that relationship
with the private sector?
And what role do they play in all these amazing
innovations that we're hearing about?
MABUS: Well, they play a critical and huge
role in a lot of this.
The way we try to keep up is by establishing
the connections.
It's also by making governmental acquisition
a little bit easier, a little bit less opaque,
and trying to take the fear factor out of-out
of people selling to the military or to the-to
the federal government.
That's not easy.
But we're doing a lot more pilot programs,
we're doing a lot more proof of concept, so
that you don't have to jump through all the
hoops to do a program of record until you
see-so you succeed fast or you fail fast,
without dragging on for years and year and
years.
And so we do that.
We also have great partnerships with universities,
with Applied Physics Lab at Johns Hopkins
or Penn State or Purdue or Arizona State or
MIT or-I can, you know, just keep listing
them on and on and on-to use some of their
cutting-edge research.
And a lot of it's funded from Naval Research
Labs, from other parts of the Navy or Marine
Corps.
And finally, the Marine Corps twice a year
has just an open house-one time, once every
six months at Quantico, and then the next
time in Twentynine Palms in California.
And they say, bring us your alternatives.
Bring us what you're making.
And that's where we got the little solar panels,
the rollable solar panels.
That's where we got the portable solar generators.
There's a technology that spray can-you spray
something on a rock, put a lead to it, and
it becomes a solar panel.
We didn't know about that, but somebody brought
it in.
And what the Marines can do is they can buy
it.
They can buy it on the spot.
Their Expeditionary Energy Office can.
And so that's one of the ways that we-you
know, just show us what you got and maybe
we'll-maybe we'll buy it, and maybe, you know,
we'll turn your small company into a-into
a much bigger company if it-if it helps us,
if it-if we've got a need for it.
And, you know, George, I don't think anybody
in here, when they think of Marines-and we
got two of them on the front row here-they
don't think about ardent environmentalists.
First thing-first thing-actually, we got three
of them on the front row here.
But they are leading the pack in terms of
that partnership with the private sector in
terms of finding what that new technology
is out there.
And if that technology is something that we
can use, we're figuring out ways to get it
quick and to keep companies from going under
just trying to get into the federal system,
because Lord knows it's way too complicated.
The last thing I'll say, at hearings the last
couple of years I've taken a chart, and it's
about this big, and it's our acquisition process.
It's the things you got to go through.
It looks like a plate of spaghetti.
And it's simplified.
I mean, I didn't-I didn't put everything on
there.
I mean, that is nuts that-the way we're doing
it today.
We got to cut out a bunch of this.
Congress has tried and, you know, we're trying.
And as I said, we're basically trying to bypass
a lot of this and do pilot programs or proof
of concept.
I mean, the laser weapon, I talked to the
reporter who wrote the article about the railgun.
I talked to him this morning.
He said that the railgun was the most-viewed
video The Wall Street Journal had done this
year.
Last year, the laser that we've got out in
the Arabian Gulf was the most-viewed video.
And the year before that, it was the X-47B,
the unmanned aerial vehicle that we landed
on a carrier and catapulted off.
He said, just keep inventing these things;
it's really helping us a publication.
(Laughter.)
You know, that laser weapon, we sent it out
in 2013 as a demonstration.
It's a 30-kilowatt laser.
It was supposed to be for six months.
They just loved the weapon.
It's really valuable.
So we're learning lessons from that.
It's still a pilot, but now we're building
a much larger weapon-the private sector is,
having learned the lessons of what does it
do in a maritime setting, what does it do
in, you know, 120-degree weather, how do you-how
do you keep it when it's not absolutely level,
as ships tend not to be.
And so learning those lessons has allowed
us to succeed way faster, and so when we go
to a program of record we'll have a lot of
those questions that that spaghetti chart
causes you to answer-we can skip big chunks
of that to get-to get more weapons like that.
Same thing with the railgun.
We're putting it as a test this year out to
see it if works, see how it works, see how
it works in different environments.
JOSKOW: I'll take another question from this
side, and then I'll move back to that side.
Yes?
Q: Secretary, thank you.
Masazumi Nakayama, Citigroup.
To keep Navy strong and keep seamen highly
motivated, what should U.S. taxpayer should
do in terms of investment of their taxpayers'
money?
And also, what kind of points that we-American
should be careful and sensitive to the U.S.
Navy?
MABUS: Well, part of my job, I think, is to
protect taxpayer money.
And I'll give you some examples.
On ships, Littoral Combat Ship was costing
about 800 million (dollars) when I came in.
It's costing 350 million (dollars) a ship
today.
We're saving $300 million per destroyer that
we're building.
We bought 10 Virginia-class submarines over
a five-year period; we paid for nine.
You know, it's like having a punch card: "buy
nine submarines, get your 10th one free."
(Laughter.)
And it's because we're doing stuff like firm
fixed-price contracts and multiyears and stable
designs and mature technology.
And so those shipyards that are building the
submarines knew how many people they were
going to have to hire and have over the next
five years.
We gave them some stability.
They knew what materials they needed to buy
for 10 submarines, and it's cheaper to buy
them for 10 than it is for one.
So we've been driving down the cost.
And I go back to-and we haven't done it at
the expense-we're building a lot more ships
for less money.
We haven't done it at the expense of aircraft.
We're buying 35 percent more aircraft than
we were in the previous seven years.
But I go back, and my father was maybe the
cheapest human being who's ever lived.
(Laughter.)
And I ran for-my first public office was state
auditor, and I was campaigning in Wiggins,
Mississippi.
And I ran into this guy, and he looked at
me and he said, are you Raymond Mabus's son?
And I said, yes, sir, I am.
And he said, well, I'm going to vote for you.
If you're half as cheap with the state's money
as your father is with his-(laughter)-we'll
be OK.
And so I'm just cheap.
I mean, I want to-I want to squeeze every
nickel till we get it.
But the reason we need a great Navy, 90 percent
of the world's trade travels by sea-90 percent.
Ninety-five percent of the data-when you're
looking at your smartphone, when you're on
the internet, 95 percent of the data goes
under the sea.
The reason the world's economy is doing as
well as it is today is the United States Navy,
because for the first time in history for
the last 70 years we have had a dominant Navy
and we've kept the sea lanes open for everybody-not
just those flying our flag or the flags of
our allies, but for everybody.
That's the reason the economy of the world
is as-is as a strong as it is today.
And so if you live in Iowa or Uganda-you know,
you're completely landlocked-you're dependent
on the sea, and you're dependent today on
the United States Navy for freedom of navigation,
for freedom of access.
And we're the only people who can do it.
And that's why you need a great Navy, is that
presence.
JOSKOW: OK.
Yes, young woman right-she's had her hand
up.
Q: Hello, Mr. Secretary.
My name is Kassia Yanosek from McKinsey and
Company.
My question's actually about conventional
energy, you know, and particularly natural
gas.
We actually have seen this huge renaissance
of natural gas.
We have decades of it at-you know, that can
be developed at quite cheap, you know, numbers.
And further, we've seen a globalization of
gas, and we keep finding lots and lots of
gas offshore.
So I'm wondering where it fits into the Navy's
strategy, particularly as you think about,
you know, electrifying your fleet.
Thank you.
MABUS: Well, first, we can't use natural gas
on our ships or our aircraft because we've
got the engines.
We've got most of the fleet we're going to
have, and we're building to the-to the fleet
size and our aircraft, none of it can use
natural gas.
I mean, it would be prohibitively expensive
to go back and retrofit it.
That's why we're looking for a drop-in fuel
instead of something like natural gas.
On our bases, we have moved to natural gas,
but I don't count it as an alternative fuel.
It's still got carbon.
It's still a non-renewable resource.
And we're finding more, and that's great.
And we're-and it's cheap, and that's great.
But it's also, as you pointed out, globalized.
It's a much more global commodity-not as much
as oil, but certainly up there.
We're not now, but could be susceptible to
price shocks there, and supply shocks, in
the same way we are with oil.
So I think that it is a valuable thing to
use, particularly in our shore establishments.
One of the ways we're using it is we're taking
out some very old, very inefficient power
plants on our bases and replacing them with
much smaller distributed power on those bases,
and powering them with natural gas.
But I think long term, if we are going to
be better warfighters-you got to-you got to
ship in natural gas.
You've got to move it from one place to the
other.
And I think it's much more valuable to be
able to make energy where you are, and it
makes-it's a military advantage to being able
to make energy where you are instead of having
to move it any amount of distance.
JOSKOW: Yes?
You're next.
Q: Thanks, Mr. Secretary.
It's Aryeh Bourkoff from LionTree.
Been a fascinating talk so far, so thank you.
There's a lot of criticism around the dysfunctionality
of government from a management perspective.
But given the fact that you've been at your
helm for seven years, talk a little bit about
not just on the innovation side, but how you
manage the scale of the Navy-the people, the
way you structure it, the way you get through
complex issues, problem solving, et cetera,
and why it's different from a lot of other
people's perspectives of government.
Thanks.
MABUS: Well, the Navy has about $170 billion
budget, Department of the Navy; 900,000 people.
If we were a private company, we'd be second-biggest
in terms of employees only after Walmart.
We'd be third-biggest in terms of assets,
between ExxonMobil and Berkshire Hathaway.
We'd be fifth-biggest in terms of budget authority.
And so it's a huge organization.
And one of the things I've learned in various
jobs-being governor, being an ambassador,
being in the private sector, being a CEO-is
that if you try to just dictate, if you try
to say we're doing it this way, nothing much
happens.
And so you've got to-you've got to give people
a reason to do it.
You've got to show them how it makes their
jobs better or their lives better.
And you've got to get complete buy-in from
the folks that work with you.
And it's particularly true in government because-you
know, I'm a political appointee.
I'm going to be gone, in fact, at the end
of this administration.
There are not many certainties in politics,
but that's one of the certainties, is-(laughter).
This was the most-requested job in the Obama
administration.
Whoever gets elected president next is going
to have a line out the door to take this job,
and it's a great job.
But the military in uniform, the civilian
workforce, they're not political, and they're
going to be there long after you leave.
So if you just try to say do this, do that,
nothing much happens.
And so you've got to-I mean, you got to show
them why it makes a difference.
In energy, it makes a difference because it
makes you better warfighters.
It affects our responsibilities-climate change
affects our responsibilities.
In terms of personnel management, you know,
we're an all-volunteer force.
We've got to recruit and we got to keep great
people.
We can't do it unless we-unless we treat them
right, unless we make their careers more flexible,
unless we-unless we give them more say, unless
we promote more on merit and less on time,
for example.
On things like acquisitions, you have to set
up systems so that-we were spending $40 billion
a year on contracts.
And so we set up a system called contract
courts, that said every contracting officer
every year has to bring in all their contracts
and defend them.
Do you still need it?
Have you bid it out lately?
You know, what are we doing with it?
I mean, these are everything from cutting
the grass to building carriers.
And so the first couple of years, we saved
$4 billion-10 percent-on that just by asking
people, why are you doing this?
What does it-what does it bring you?
And one of the results has been that people
are now bringing stuff up that they see.
You've got to-you've got to try to change
the culture.
You've got to try to change the outlook.
And the only way you do that is by having
policies or programs that do make a difference.
Not doing too many of them.
I mean, the scope of the ability to change
is pretty limited.
I mean, I was governor of the poorest state
in the nation.
Every day I got up, there were about a thousand
things I could do, I think, to make life better.
If I tried all thousand, I was going to fail
at each one.
You got to-you got to pick three or four things
and just be relentless about that.
And Tom Oppel is sitting here, my chief of
staff, who was my communications director
when I was governor.
And, you know, just repetition is the key
to clear communications.
You just got to just do it over and over and
over again, and explain it over and over and
over again, not assume that just because you're
inside it every day that everybody else is
paying attention, or cares, and that you got
to do your job and explain.
JOSKOW: Right here, and then I'll come back
to Padma (sp).
Q: You really answered the-you really answered
the question about leadership, which I was
going to ask.
Thank you.
MABUS: Thanks.
JOSKOW: Thank you.
Padma (sp)?
Q: Thank you.
How does our totally efficient naval fleet
allow us in dealing with antagonistic activities,
such as the Chinese building islands in the
waters of South China Sea?
Does it help us better to deal with these
activities, or does it involve a military
conflict, or?
MABUS: Well, the way it helps us deal with
any potential adversary or anything like that
is it allows us to be there.
And these freedom of navigation exercises
that we're doing, we're going to sail where
we are allowed to under international law.
We think that the status quo should not be
changed unilaterally or by force.
And by being-number one, by having the ships,
just having the ships to be everywhere that
we need to be to do these exercises and these
demonstrations everywhere, but then having
the power, the energy to keep them at sea,
to be everywhere, to be there when we need
them to be there-and we need them to be there
all the time-that makes us.
It's the presence.
It's the presence argument.
That's why, you know, I started out by saying
that's what we uniquely give the country.
So it doesn't matter what the threat is, or
it doesn't matter what the issue is.
Being there-there's no second-best thing to
being there.
Ships in port in the United States don't do
us much good.
You have to have them, and it can't just be
in one sea or one ocean.
We have to have them everywhere, all the time.
We're the only global navy and we're the only
one who can do this, and we're the only one-we're
the ones that people look to.
And so that's why we need the number of ships,
and that's why they need to be at sea.
JOSKOW: Yes?
Q: Me or him?
JOSKOW: Yes, him.
(Laughter.)
Q: Herbert Levin, Council member.
From a standpoint of the national well-being
is it more important that the Navy have more
potent guns or that high-school graduates
in Mississippi can go to MIT paid for?
MABUS: Well, I don't think that's a choice
we ought to make.
I think you ought to do both.
Q: Raise taxes.
MABUS: Well, let me-let me-let me tell you
something.
Let me give you a statistic that's going to
frighten you.
It does me.
Three out of four Americans age 18 to 24 do
not qualify for the U.S. military-three out
of four.
Our recruiting pool is 25 percent of our total
population.
They don't qualify because they didn't finish
high school.
They don't qualify because of health issues,
mainly obesity.
They don't qualify because they've got a criminal
record.
We don't give any waivers to get into the
military.
But that ought to frighten us.
We ought to do a better job in terms of health
care.
We ought to do a better job in terms of education.
I mean, I spent a large part of my live working
on education in Mississippi.
And I don't care if you don't have children,
I don't care if you don't have children in
public schools, I don't care if your children
are out of school, you've got a vested interest
in making sure that our public schools are
great.
You just do.
And I went and I made a speech to the Mississippi
legislature in 2011.
It's the first time I talked to them since
I left office in 1992.
I made the same speech in 2011 I did in 1992.
I mean, I started out by saying, as I was
saying when I got interrupted.
(Laughter.)
But, you know, every one of those legislators
came up to me and said, what can we do to
help the military?
We want to help you.
And I said, OK, you want to help us?
Do better in education.
You want to help us?
Do better in health care.
Keep people in school and out of jail.
That's the way you can help the military.
So I just think that's a false choice.
I think we've got to-we've got to do both.
JOSKOW: Well, on that note, the witching hour
is here.
We end our Council meetings on time.
I'd like-please give Secretary Mabus a round
of applause for a fascinating discussion.
(Applause.)
And thank you all for coming.
I'm sorry we couldn't get to all the questions.
(END)